guten abend meine damen und herren zur
pressekonferenz nach der
fraktionssitzung mit den
fraktionsvorsitzenden
bald brinkhaus und herrn dumm und
sehr geehrte damen und herren herzlich
willkommen heute abend nach der
gemeinsamen fraktionssitzung wir haben
diese gemeinsame fraktion konstituiert
heute und haben sowohl in csu tal als
auch im cdu teil als auch gemeinsam die
fraktionsgemeinschaft wieder neu für die
zwanzigste wahlperiode jeweils
einstimmig so beschlossen so dass wir
als gemeinsame fraktion wieder auftreten
und haben heute den
fraktionsvorsitzenden auch gewählt ich
darf hier ganz herzlich gratulieren an
dieser stelle
ralph brinkhaus zum neu gewählten
fraktionsvorsitzende der gemeinsamen cdu
csu fraktion mit 85 prozent der stimmen
gewählt hier an dieser stelle auch noch
mal ganz herzlichen glückwunsch liberal
viel erfolg und eine weiterhin sehr gute
zusammenarbeit
und das wird es auch werden die gute
zusammenarbeit wir hatten natürlich in
der fraktionssitzung eine aussprache das
ist ganz klar nach so einem wahlergebnis
es war eine sehr sachliche aussprache
die wir gehabt haben und insofern
blicken wir jetzt nach vorne es ist
jetzt geklärt wie die zusammensetzung
ist wir haben den
anderen teil des fraktionsvorstandes das
heißt außer alexander dobrindt und ich
kommissarisch im amt bestätigt zumindest
diejenigen die jetzt auch im deutschen
bundestag geblieben sind das sind ja
auch einige ausgeschieden und das heißt
also wir sind voll arbeitsfähig und das
werden wir jetzt auch entsprechend
umsetzen
morgen früh wird sich der
geschäftsführende vorstand das erste mal
treffen und dann geht es los und
insofern freuen wir uns auf das was
jetzt kommen wird der sonntag war kein
schöner tag aber jetzt gucken wir nach
vorne vielen dank kommen wir nun zu
ihren fragen herr rinke von der
nachrichtenagentur reuters mit ihre
frage ich hätte eine frage an herrn
dobrindt
heute mittag gesagt dass das die woche
der entscheidung ist sowohl inhaltlich
wie personell ich hätte ganz gerne
gewusst ob nach dieser entscheidung für
ein brinkhaus die personellen
entscheidungen abgeschlossen sind für
diese woche oder ob weitere kommen die
sie uns ankündigen können und was heißt
dass herr trikots für die stellung von
herr laschet angesichts der heftigen
diskussionen die es ja auch in der
fraktion um seine person und faden foto
gab
ja zu ihrer ersten frage wir haben heute
eine zentrale ganz wichtige
personalentscheidung getroffen in der
fraktion ich habe ja auch darauf
gedrängt dass wir diese entscheidung
heute treffen da hat es ja auch an
anderer stelle diskussionen gegeben und
ich bin sehr froh dass wir eine
gemeinsame sichtweise hier an den tag
gelegt haben und diese wichtige
entscheidung getroffen haben das ist für
diese woche schon mal ganz gut glaube
ich weitere habe ich jetzt nicht aktuell
anzukündigen an personalentscheidungen
ja und ansonsten ist es so dass wir
jetzt in gespräche reingehen werden
gespräche anbieten werden und das ist
ganz klar das ist natürlich alle diese
funktionen sind eingebunden sind und es
ist so dass wir als fraktion aber schon
sagen wir wollen eine starke stellung
haben wir wollen damit reden und wir
werden auch nicht jeden kompromiss
mitmachen sondern wir wollen unseren
markenkern halten ich habe das heute
mittag auch schon mal gesagt und das ist
jetzt der weg wie wir jetzt in den
gespräche dann rein gehen werden und
natürlich ist es so dass die beiden
parteivorsitzenden da eine zentrale
rolle spielen vielen dank frau lau von
derzeit ihre frage bitte
ein bisschen mehr über die diskussionen
erzählen die stadt befunden haben
also ich fand sie eigentlich relativ
sachlich die diskussion ist ja so ich
sag das ja ganz offen da saßen natürlich
viele enttäuschte kolleginnen und
kollegen im saal einige die ja auch
super super lange für die fraktion
gearbeitet haben die sich der toll
eingebracht haben die nicht
wiedergewählt worden sind und insofern
war es also insgesamt eine sehr
sachliche diskussion mit dem breiten
meinungsspektrum sicherlich war die eine
oder andere enttäuschung braucht dabei
da brauchen wir uns auch überhaupt
nichts vormachen aber es hat sich dann
doch gezeigt dass in der krise dann doch
irgendwo der zusammenhalt entsprechend
da ist und insofern war das auch gut und
wichtig und es müssen ja auch sachen
auch einfach mal ausgesprochen werden
das gehört ja auch dazu kann ja jetzt
nicht irgendwie so tun als wenn alles
normal ist und wie eine ganz normale
legislaturperiode haben es ist schon
sehr ungewöhnlich aber es war also ganz
ganz überwiegend vom willen getragen
jetzt nach vorne zu schauen im zentrum
der diskussionen stand so kann man das
glaube ich sagen dass es seine
bereitschaft gibt verantwortung zu
übernehmen
dass das aber nicht mit einem ausverkauf
der eigenen positionen und
eigenen
themenbereiche einhergehen kann
und darüber hat sich haben wir mal sehr
viel in der debatte gedreht dass die
richtige balance gehalten werden muss
aus verantwortung einerseits
und der glaubwürdigkeit der eigenen
positionen auf der anderen seite und das
ist dann in einem gesamtbild natürlich
dazu gehört dass auch aufarbeitung von
den vergangenen monaten stattfindet das
auch das eine oder andere kritische
bemerkung stattfindet glaube ich ist
sogar notwendig und zwingend und
deswegen über die einzelnen
wortmeldungen geben wir hier ja keine
auskunft aber ich habe den verdacht dass
sie die ohnehin irgendwo mitbekommen
haben das stück herr feldhof vom zweiten
deutschen fernsehen ihre frage bitte
wenn ich das richtig sehe richtig
beurteile ist ja den vorschlag von der
brinkhaus zur wahl von beiden
parteivorsitzendem einsam in einem
kompromiss vorgeschlagen worden warum
sind die beiden parteivorsitzenden jetzt
nicht hier um ihnen zu gratulieren und
uns rede und antwort zu stehen
na ja also wir haben sie gratuliert
auch sehr nett und es ist ja jetzt so
eine sache das ist eine sache der
fraktion ist das heißt also wir sind die
fraktionen wir sind auch so
selbstbewusst dass er für uns selber
sprechen können und ich glaube es ist
auch das richtige zeichen ja das war
jetzt ergeben dass weil er selber
sprechen das ist ganz freundschaftlich
wir haben uns da abgesprochen und haben
gesagt wir beiden machen das und
insofern sind die beiden anderen jetzt
schon zu weiteren gesprächen unterwegs
das soll ja ganz gute arbeitsteilung ich
kann ihnen versichern dass
beide parteivorsitzenden auch ohne
fotobeweis ralph brinkhaus persönlich
gratuliert haben
die nächste frage frau hasenkamm von der
südwest presse
ich habe noch mal eine frage zu den
koalitionsverhandlungen was ist denn
jetzt die linie nach dieser
fraktionssitzung herr brinkhaus sie
haben gerade gesagt sie werden gespräche
anbieten den csu-chef habe ich vorhin so
verstanden dass sozusagen jetzt erstmal
abgewartet wird ob jemand nach
möglicherweise gescheiterter ampel auf
sie zukommt aber sie klangen jetzt
gerade wieder als ob sie aktiv werden
wollen na ja also ich meine wir müssen
ja unsere gesprächsbereitschaft
signalisieren ja das gehört ja dazu also
ich meine werden ja jetzt auch sagen
können also wir sprechen mit niemand wir
sind beleidigt und haben jetzt irgendwo
keine lust mit jemandem zu sprechen das
entspricht aber nicht unseren
verantwortungsgefühl und das ist ja auch
das was in der fraktionssitzung in
vielen vielen wortbeiträgen gekommen ist
dass wir verantwortung übernehmen wollen
und übernehmen müssen das heißt aber
jetzt nicht dass wir das aus einer
position raus machen so hallo wir
organisieren das jetzt sondern aus einer
position heraus machen wo wir sagen als
demokratische partei stehen wir da zur
verfügung wir würden gerne sprechen wir
würden auch gerne verantwortung
übernehmen und alles andere wird sich
jetzt ergeben weil wir ja auch eine sehr
ungewöhnliche konstellation haben das
muss auch sagen in sofern überhaupt kein
widerspruch zwischen dem was ich gesagt
habe und was markus söder gesagt hat
absolut es handelt sich auch nicht um
koalitionsverhandlungen sondern
sondierungen um die es jetzt geht
und wir haben heute besprochen dass wir
aktiv unsere gesprächsbereitschaft
anmelden
und das heißt jetzt nicht nur über die
medien und über die öffentlichkeit
unsere gesprächsbereitschaft formulieren
sondern dass wir sie auch aktiv
gegenüber
möglichen sondierungs partnern zu
erkennen geben die nächste frage frau
dunns von redaktions netzwerk
deutschland bitte
das ist hier irgendwie so so zierte die
mikrofone wir sind auf das andere marken
frage an sie beide in welchem zeitrahmen
bewegt sich das was sie gerade gesagt
haben dass sie ihre
gesprächsbereitschaft anmelden läuft das
parallel zu dem was union übers grüne
und fdp mit der spd plan und wäre in
solchen verhandlungen herr laschet für
sie der geeignete verhandler oder würde
sich das auf herrn söder konzentrieren
und herr laschet damit er den weg
freimachen müssen
also wir sind ein team wir haben das
auch gerade in der fraktionssitzung im
team gemacht das ist armin laschet das
ist markus söder das ist alexander
dobrindt das ist ralph brinkhaus weil
die fraktion noch eine starke rolle
spielen will und auch eine starke rolle
spielen muss und insofern betrachten wir
uns da als mannschaft
niemand verhandelt alleine das habe ich
heute nachmittag hier auch hier betont
es kann nur gemeinsame verhandlungen
geben sowohl was die beiden parteien
anbelangt als auch was die fraktion
anbelangt die parteien können ohne die
fraktionsführung diese sondierungen auch
nicht durchführen da legen wir auch
absoluten wert darauf das war auch heute
in der fraktionssitzung sehr sehr
deutlich dass es einen ausgesprochen
beteiligungs wunsch der fraktionen an
diesen möglichen sondierungen gibt weil
das auch genau der sicherung des
markenkerns von cdu und csu auch in
verhandlungen dienen soll und
dementsprechend auch nachdruck verleihen
soll ergebnis von verhandlungen kann am
schluss ja auch nur mit der zustimmung
einer fraktion erfolgen und deswegen
legen wir auch der besondere wert drauf
und das heißt genau so kann man das
sehen niemand verhandelt alleine es geht
um die beiden parteivorsitzenden
es geht um den fraktionsvorsitzenden im
vorsitzender csu im deutschen bundestag
ist sind diejenigen die da vorhanden
sehr gut
[Musik]
jetzt kenne ich den zeitrahmen der ampel
sondierungen nicht weiß nicht ob sie ihn
kennen aber dazu habe ich ja keine
einladung das heißt also es
kann jetzt keine abschließende antwort
auf diese frage geben ich habe gesagt es
geht um relativ schnell wir haben einen
kurzen zeitplan vor augen es braucht
klarheit in der öffentlichkeit wir
können jetzt keine hängepartie brauchen
das würde auch die mögliche zustimmung
zu egal welcher konstellation in der
öffentlichkeit nicht vergrößern sondern
verkleinern wir haben alle noch im kopf
wie vor vier jahren die
verhandlungen waren da hat man sich aus
sondierungen heraus
übergangslosen koalitionsverhandlungen
hinein entwickelt das wird dieses mal
erkennbar nicht so sein also das wird
nach sondierungen natürlich auch einen
bruch geben und dann wird man sehen
welche koalitionsverhandlungen wie
aufgenommen werden können und allein das
bedingt schon dass es nur einen sehr
schmalen
zeitplan geben kann in denen man diese
sondierungen abschließen muss wir reden
hier nicht über mehrere wochen uns sehr
deutlich zu sagen die nächste frage herr
de ziehen vom deutschlandradio bitte
herrn dobrindt können sie mit der
klarheit diese gerade versprochen haben
auch sagen dass armin laschet nach wie
vor in den gesprächen diese führen
wollen der kanzlerkandidat der union und
auch der cdu/csu es
ich habe jetzt überhaupt keine anderen
andeutungen irgendeine richtung gemacht
wir verhandeln gemeinsam jeder in seiner
position die er aktuell auch wahrnimmt
meine damen und herren herzlichen dank
für ihr interesse
dankeschön schönen abend
ja das war also die presse erkennt neue
alle gespannt gewartet haben ich muss
irgendwie geschielt haben meine damen
und herren ist jedenfalls haben sich
selber gemerkt die beiden
parteivorsitzenden waren und dabei das
ist übrigens ungewöhnlich sowohl heute
morgen wie auch jetzt wo es gibt noch
eine frage ich geben um reinheit zu
zeigen und da ist es dann so gewesen
dass wird an uns darauf geeinigt haben
oder die parteivorsitzenden das also
entsprechend vorgeschlagen haben dass
wir das bis zum 30 04 machen und dann
sehen wir auch entsprechend weiter aber
ich habe da viel freude daran und ich
will da auch mich bemühen dass nach dem
30 10 vierten weiterzumachen
dank
herr drogen gerade sie wollte ich fragen
sie haben das mehrfach betont heute
nutzen wir uns ja nicht nicht preis
geben werde
sie haben mehr von entschuldigung sie
haben mehrfach betont heute dass die
union in fahnen möglichen verhandlungen
den markenkern der union nicht preis
geben werde können sie kurz umreißen was
ist der markenkern um dienst da geht
ein kurzer kann ich nicht lang kann ich
das sehr wohl aber
wir haben ja deutlich gemacht dass es
uns wenn wir jetzt in sondierung kämen
um auch darüber drei große elemente geht
über die man diskutieren muss das eines
wirtschaftliches wachstum und dynamik
die geschaffen werden muss der
themenbereich klimaschutz und
beschleunigung des
klimaschutzes ist uns auch ein großes
anliegen und natürlich in diesem rahmen
ein wichtiger gesprächspunkt weil man
hier vereinbarungen finden müsste und
der dritte punkt ist die sicherheit
äußere und innere sicherheit
bündnisfähigkeit verlässlichkeit in
internationalen angelegenheiten die in
so einem rahmen diskutiert werden müsste
wann haben wir noch zwei fragen
entschuldigung zum abschluss ok herr
ziegler von der stuttgarter zeitung
bitte
es gibt ja viele auch in ihrer fraktion
die sagen wir müssten eigentlich die
reihenfolge einhalten erst wird über die
ampel verhandelt und wenn das nicht
zustande kommt müssten wir als
zweitplatzierte uns dann programmatisch
anbieten als alternative aber eben erst
wenn die ampel sozusagen ausverhandelt
ist oder aus sondiert ist
söder hat sicherheit nachmittag auch
dahingehend geäußert dass
olaf scholz die besseren kanzler chancen
hat also warum tut sich die union so
schwer da eine gemeinsame linie zu
finden weil jetzt wird ja eben doch
offensichtlich parallel sondiert
also wir haben gesagt wir bieten unsere
gesprächsbereitschaft und das gehört
sich auch so als demokratische partei
und natürlich haben wir ein interesse
daran dass wir eine koalition mit formen
können und jetzt muss man einfach
schauen jetzt ist es so dass sich die
liberalen und die grünen zusammen setzen
wie gesagt unser angebot steht jetzt
schauen wir mal was sich entwickelt weil
wir sind ja jetzt wirklich nicht in
einer situation wo es irgendwie so
klassisch ist weil wir haben ja schon
ein komisches wahlergebnis das muss man
ja sagen also ist nicht sehr dicht
beieinander ist in zwei koalition
möglich es ist so dass zwei kleine
partner irgendwo immer dabei sind in den
beiden koalitionsoptionen und das ist
sehr ungewöhnlich und dementsprechend
müssen sie auch damit rechnen dass in
dieser woche auch das nicht unbedingt
alles irgendwo wie auf schienen passiert
und jetzt schauen wir mal einfach was in
den nächsten tagen passiert und
vielleicht ist ja auch richtig ja wir
haben ja jetzt mal uns konstituierte als
fraktion die anderen fraktionen an dass
da so größtenteils auch gemacht also ab
heute ist dann auch die arbeitsfähigkeit
dann entsprechend also in der neuen
konstellation hergestellt wir schauen
was die nächsten tage so bringen und
vielleicht ist ja auch noch nicht
angenommen also sie stellen die frage
hier an uns warum macht ihr parallel
oder eins nach dem anderen oder erst die
ampel dann jamaika oder umgekehrt es
hängt ja nicht an uns sondern wir geben
unser angebot ab wir würden gerne diese
gespräche führen aber jetzt waren welche
termine stattfinden hängt ja sehr stark
auch vom jeweiligen gesprächspartner ab
und dazu stehen ja dann die antworten
entsprechend aus so dass man diese frage
gleichzeitig hintereinander erst nach
den ersten kontaktaufnahmen beantworten
kann und ich kann ihnen sagen wenn man
die fraktion sich anschaut dann ist der
wille dieser fraktion da dass diese
gespräche stattfinden und die frage in
welcher reihenfolge das macht steht im
hintergrund da hat jeder so seine idee
dazu aber dazu gibt es jetzt keine
abschließenden vereinbarungen sondern
wir sind sehr interessiert daran dass
man das jetzt mit der fdp mit den grünen
zu gesprächen führt aber wie dies
zustande kommen hängt auch von unseren
möglichen sondierungs partnern und hier
vorne die letzte frage bitte
afrika ist heute nachmittag war der
sitzung war von einem kompromiss für
eine halbes jahr die regel bis zum 30
vierter sind wenn ich mich nicht
verrechnet habe aber sieben monate wurde
über einzelne monate gefälscht oder was
hat es damit auf sich da wohl nicht
gefallen aneinander wurde gerundet und
es ist so dass der bundestag sich erst
am 26 oktober konstituiert und das kann
man jetzt irgendwie so oder so sehen
aber das hier ist echt kein thema
gewesen also wir haben ja jetzt nicht um
tage gezeigt das ist nicht der fall
gewesen
so aber ist ein guter grundsatz die
rundung ist die lösung ja danke schön
alles gute
ja meine damen und herren es läuft
nichts normal bei der union in diesen
tagen auch diese pressekonferenz etwas
ungewöhnlich die beiden
parteivorsitzenden nicht dabei danach
wurde auch gefragt auch das ist sehr
ungewöhnlich normalerweise stehen die
parteivorsitzenden vorher gemeinsam
ihren kandidaten vor wir sehen jetzt
ralph brinkhaus der bis zum april
vorläufig erst mal gewählt wurde und
alexander dobrindt der ordnungsgemäß als
landesgruppenchef vier jahre lang
gewählt worden ist das hält die csu
offensichtlich ganz anders als die cdu
das war aber immer schon so brinkhaus
wirkt entspannt dem ist erstmal ein
stein von der seele gefallen das war
natürlich im vorfeld auch die frage was
passiert hier heute gibt es hier
kampfkandidaturen und die beiden
parteivorsitzenden laschet und söder
haben das ganze dann entschärft indem
sie also die normale zeitspanne von
einem jahr auf faktisch sieben monate
verkürzt haben damit hat die union dann
die möglichkeit wenn sie dann in der
opposition ist noch mal zu verhandeln
wer soll denn diesen wichtigen posten
des oppositionsführers dann ab april
einnehmen diese sitzung hier neben mir
und mir im plenarsaal des deutschen
bundestages sie muss ja recht heftig
zugange gewesen sein es ist nur ein
bisschen was raus gesichert aber unter
anderem hat gitta connemann sie
stellvertretende fraktionsvorsitzende
gewesene letzten legislaturperiode und
sylvia pantel sie ist eine der
abgeordneten die ihren wahlkreis
verloren haben und raus ist aus dem
parlament beide haben den rücktritt
gefordert von armin laschet sylvia
pantel hat außerhalb des plenarsaals
wörtlich gesagt er hat die partei vor
die wand gefahren die wahlen vor die
wand gefahren pardon und da sieht man
schon wie die stimmung in teilen der
fraktion ist auch die ostdeutschen sind
sehr verbittert über schlechte
abschneiden der cdu und führen das zu
100% auf den kandidaten zurück das ist
hart denn natürlich hat armin laschet
diese wahlniederlage nicht allein zu
verschulden
es ist auch für armin laschet ein
problem das ja mit markus söder jemanden
hat der immer noch nach tritt auch am
heutigen tage auch das ist heraus
gesichert in der rede von markus söder
hat markus söder wohl darauf hingewiesen
dass unter angela merkel die war die
wahlumfragen bzw die umfragen immer gut
aussahen und auch wichtig waren und da
hat er dann darauf angespielt dass das
eben bei armin laschet nicht der fall
war und armin laschet immer gesagt hat
die umfragen sind das eine abgerechnet
wird nach dem wahltag das muss markus
söder ansonsten offen stehen gelassen
haben aber das ist natürlich alles
andere als eine rückendeckung ein
schulterschluss und wenn alexander
dobrindt sagt die beiden waren
parteichefs waren jetzt hier nicht dabei
weil sie in weiteren gesprächen sind
dann denke ich mal sie sollten erst mal
gespräche miteinander führen und markus
söder sollte sich entscheiden ob er sich
nun zu dem cdu-chef weiter bekennt oder
ob er daran weiter arbeitet ihn zu
demontieren
ja und die cdu/csu bietet also sich an
um jamaika gespräche zu führen auch das
ist in der fraktion teilweise
unterschiedlich aufgenommen worden die
mehrzahl so habe ich gehört ist
eigentlich eher dafür die spd zunächst
verhandeln zu lassen über eine ampel so
ist es auch üblich und dann wenn das
scheitern sollte ist ja die cdu noch da
die fraktionsspitze und die parteispitze
neigt dazu also jetzt das angebot zu
machen haben wir das läuft auch so ein
bisschen die zeit weg habe ich das
gefühl und deswegen will man sich hier
weiter ins gespräch bringen wenn man
einen strich unter den heutigen tag
macht muss man sagen die cdu csu hat
sich mit einem kunstgriff hier noch mal
gerettet keine kampfabstimmung ich sage
nur die konservativen in der fraktion
zum beispiel friedrich merz iren sparen
andere die noch zugriff haben wollen auf
diesen wichtigen posten sind erst einmal
befriedet worden damit das heute nicht
die endgültige abstimmung war ja und zum
anderen bietet man sich also wie gesagt
an alles ein bisschen durcheinander ein
bisschen chaotisch nach einer ganz herbe
niederlage aber
das ende der wahlen haben wir noch nicht
erlebt denn eine regierung muss erstmal
gebildet werden und bei einer jamaika
option oder was kann aber in einer
großen koalition wäre die cdu csu
tatsächlich dann doch noch mal in
regierungsverantwortung zunächst jedoch
war sicherlich die frage
überlebt armin laschet den heutigen tag
hier das hat er getan es war eine sehr
harte sitzung wieder mal für ihn und es
ist sicherlich nicht einfach so viel
gegenwind zu spüren aber wir haben in
deutschland kennt weiß von selber wird
er nicht weichen an ihm alleine hat es
ja auch nicht gelegen und damit zurück
in unser bonner studio ja eine frage
habe ich doch geld hier auch in pfund
follower das war es ja schon eine ganze
rundum einordnung eigentlich aber so ein
bisschen würde ich gerne noch von der
stimmung erspüren sehr mir schon ein
bisschen
geschildert dampf ist etwas
herausgekommen bei der fraktionssitzung
ihre einschätzung glauben sie dass es ja
damit jetzt erstmal gut ist dass auch
eben mit der wahl von brinkhaus zum
fraktionsvorsitzende mit denen der mit
diesem kompromiss jetzt erst einmal ein
bisschen frieden eingekehrt ist für die
nächsten tage oder können wir uns schon
wieder auf saftige neue schlagzeilen
morgen früh einstellen
ich glaube wir können uns auf weitere
schlagzeilen einstellen das liegt auch
daran dass in der ganzen sache nicht nur
cdu csu beteiligt ist sondern auch die
öffentlichkeit auch von außen wird ja
vieles herangetragen dann liegt es daran
dass armin laschet gesagt hat er wird
auf jeden fall nach berlin wechseln
damit macht er den
ministerpräsidentenposten in
nordrhein-westfalen jafry auch da gibt
es kämpfe um seine nachfolge und die
soll wie wir hören bis ende nächster
woche dann auch die sollen dort erledigt
sein armin laschet muss an mehreren
fronten kämpfen und die unzufriedenheit
gerade auch in der cdu allenthalben ist
doch sehr groß und wenn man dann noch so
einen partner hat wie markus söder dann
kann man sicher sein dass man nicht aus
den schlagzeilen heraus kommt es ist
eine harte zeit für armin laschet mal
sehen wie lange er das durchsteht